elle était attendue elle n'a pas déçu
émilie menuet championne de france du
10000 m marche
qualifié pour les mondiaux de pékin la
sociétaire de l' aj blois onzain
confirme un très bon début de saison
de l'argent qui vaut de l'or pour la
loire et anne-sophie dangla de l'eco cjf
qualifié de dernière minute sur les
championnats elle monte sur la deuxième
marche du podium à la perche elle même
mais j'attendais pas forcément sec
grosse surprise stoïque des conditions
comme aujourd'hui j'ai tout passé au
premier essai donc sac avec le vent de
face a été vraiment un concours délicat
et voilà j'ai fait ce qu'il fallait au
bon moment et ça a payé donc est
vraiment contente l'argent ne fait pas
vraiment le bonheur des garçons le
tourangeau qu'il y adhérer chou est
toujours en deçà de ses espérances au
javelot
le podium n'est pas une consolation le
loire est un frédéric d'âge et fort mes
amis espérait lui passer le cap des 20 m
au lancer poids 19 mètres 36 2e
il prend malgré tout c'est mon meilleur
résultat quand même je fais du champion
de france j'ai fait qu'une fois avec une
perte comme ça je peux pas cracher
dessus
je suis encore jeune c'est d'expérience
à apprendre de l'expérience salim sdiri
en à bientôt 37 ans pour le montargois
spécialiste du saut en longueur 7 m 59
petite paire four lui ils montrent
malgré tout sur la troisième marche du
podium
une médaille d'or trois médailles
d'argent une médaille de bronze
beau tir groupé nos régionaux et ce
n'est pas fini spectateurs hier acteurs
aujourd'hui nos champions sont prêts ne
fais pas de soucis mais il faut rester
concentré parce que la saison est encore
longue
je vise les championnats du monde à
pékin donc j'ai pas encore scellé
minimale et je travaille pour donc un
titre national à défendre au lancer de
disque d'autres médailles aller chercher
reprise des réjouissances cet après midi